If you're hiking pretty
much anywhere in the US,
this is one sound you don't want to hear.
The warning of a rattlesnake.
Now, just because a rattlesnake's tail
sounds like a built-in maraca
doesn't mean it works like one.
There are no beads rattling about in here.
So, what's really going on inside?
If you opened up a rattlesnake's
rattle and shook it,
absolutely nothing would fall out.
After all...
Tim Colston: So, rattlesnake
rattles are hollow.
Narrator: That's
herpetologist Tim Colston.
He says the secret to that rattling sound
comes from the shell itself.
It's made of keratin,
the same hard substance
as your fingernails.
The keratin is arranged in a
chain of interlocking rings,
which are hooked together by
tiny grooves along their edge.
Now, watch what happens to those rings
when Colston shakes the rattle.
Colston: Whenever I shake them very fast,
they bump together, producing the sound.
Narrator: Because the
rattle is hollow inside,
sound waves can bounce
off the walls and echo,
the same way shouting in a
cave amplifies the sound.
And the bigger the cave, or
hollow rings in this case,
the more amplification,
so the louder the rattle.
But a big, hollow chamber can't
get the job done on its own.
That's where the tail muscles come in.
Rattlesnakes are equipped with
three powerful shaker muscles
at the base of their spine.
These can contract so fast,
they vibrate the rattle
up to 90 times a second.
For comparison, the human eye blinks
15 to 20 times a minute.
By vibrating so quickly,
the rattle makes a sound that hits
between these specific frequencies.
And it just so happens that that range
is best heard by mammals.
It turns out, that tail is custom designed
to make predators like bears, raccoons,
and weasels listen up.
Unfortunately, snakelets
(yes, that's what baby snakes are called),
don't have this warning signal.
Colston: Whenever a rattlesnake is born,
it just has a single button.
It looks similar to the one,
I don't know if you can
see, that's on the end here.
Narrator: Without a second
button to clack against,
the baby rattle can't make any noise.
But every time they shed their skin,
they add another button
to the base of the rattle,
which grows into the segment above,
sort of like the structure
of a Russian stacking doll.
The rattle will keep growing until...snap!
Just like your fingernails,
those rattles are pretty fragile,
and they can break off
if they get too long.
In fact, the rattles rarely
make it past eight to 10 rings
before snapping off.
Luckily, snakes shed their entire lives.
So the rattle will grow back good as new,
which is good news for you hikers,
because that handy tail
can mean the difference
between an exciting day on the trail
and a painful trip to the hospital.